[Music]
let's go to Charleston and talk
to is there a song called Ellen no I've
never heard of a song with the main
character Ellen you should get on that
bin all right what's up Ellen oh I guess
I got to push the button and welcome you
back hey what's up Ellen hi Dr D hey uh
Kelly's rolling her eyes she's like wow
how long we've done this show three
years and you don't to work this
computer good to talk to you Ellen
what's up um well so my husband and I
have found ourselves in sort of pickle
um so love pickles all right uh long
story short uh couple of years ago well
2021 we decided to sell our house and at
the time we had a one-year-old we were
taking care of my husband's grandmother
who was 90 and we were working full-time
jobs in the health care field around Co
um little background can I say something
mean your life sucked in 21
good yeah so um and on top of that my
husband he um does have little OCD
anxiety working in the healthc care
field with germs just sort of sent that
an
overdrive um so with especially a
newborn at the time we uh pretty much
just sort of shut down our lives um so
during that time we sort of just became
exiled we're just working jobs taking
care of our baby and um taking care of
his grandmother so anyways we decided to
sell our house and at that time his
parents wanted to downsize so he said we
would buy their home from them they
would live with us for about a year till
they found some place to live and then
they would go their separate way and we
would have ours I can tell are they
still there yes oh
gosh oh no so you bought their house yes
and they were GNA leave quote unquote
later yes oh
Ellen Oh Ellen
hey man I don't smoke I just don't but I
want to have a cigarette right
now like right now so hey have you got
to see ringside seat where your
husband's ADHD and OCD emerged
from um well
so you're so kind and loving all right
go ahead go ahead yeah anyway so yep so
that's sure where we found ourselves so
now we're in the situation that my
husband has just sort of gotten to the
end of his line that he's like okay I
can't live with my parents anymore um so
the situation we're in right now is we
can buy another home and keep the
current home and his parents would like
rent from us in essence or we could sell
the home and buy a larger home so the
home we could afford right now would
would be fine but in a couple years we
would want to upgrade to another home so
Ellen Ellen Ellen Ellen y'all are gonna
spend hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of dollars to avoid a
conversation yeah don't do that don't do
that and by the way this is not your
conversation to have this is your
husband needs to be a
grownup and within the next week set up
a meeting with your M with his mom and
dad to arrange an exit strategy for them
an exit strategy is y'all have 90 days
yeah this is not your problem to solve I
hate that and and normally you if you've
ever listened to the show I always tell
y'all are in this thing together and
this is y this is your husband's
conversation to have with his parents
this is a matter of
Integrity they need to leave your
house within 90
days you will never be able to
sleep yeah not
yourself and both literally and
metaphorically with your
husband if he spends
$500,000 running away from a hard
conversation with his mommy and his
daddy
M I don't know how you could possibly
respect him if he does
that and I think the problem like so I
come from a family that like I don't
know if you have a problem you just sort
of speak your mind it might piss them
off for a second or two but we in
essence respect each other you know why
cuz you're an
adult you came from a grownup family way
to go alen
yeah Hey listen listen there is no
um I only because I've I've sat with
medical professionals and gotten the
same Diagnostics your husband has
there's not an excuse I don't care yeah
I know like in that family we just don't
have you do
now cuz you're in my home with my child
with my family it's
time yeah and I guess we we have had to
have or tried to have those
conversations with his mom especially um
his dad it's it's not really his stepdad
because when his mom remarried my
husband was already an adult but we'll
say it's stepdad you know they he calls
him dad um but they don't have that
relationship
that that that actually makes it
easier okay this is a
transaction so I feel like every like
said we've said hey we just want to know
what are your guys' game plans no you
know what their game plan is no why
would they leave they have everything
they live in y'all's house y'all pay the
bills just make it a business
transaction this is the deal you have 90
days and you're you got to find
something it's it's a little more delic
it but it would be your husband not you
because you add some complexity to it
okay I wish that wasn't the case but you
do your husband takes his mom and his
step dadish sort of dad or guy that
remarried when he was an adult but he
calls Dad yeah that
honestly not this is a tangent that
tells me what I need to know about your
husband he's so uncomfortable with any
sort of relational discomfort period
he's willing to call a guy that he's
didn't meet until he was out of the
house who married his mom dad yeah
that's all I need to you know what I'm
saying that's not that's
odd like that's out of a will Ferell
movie like brothers got a hug right that
I mean it's
like but here we are that's what I need
to know about your husband okay he needs
to take both of those adults out and say
y'all have been with us for 2 years we
bought your house from you with a plan
that y'all were going to stay with us
for a while and you're going to find
your place it's time for me and my
family to establish our own roots in our
own
home and that is where he'll normally go
so what are y'all thinking what are your
plans are they're not thinking anything
other than they've got it made in the
shade yeah so Mom by March one we're GNA
have to ask you to move out and find
your own place me and my family need our
own
home period
end the
story oh you're just throwing us out no
no no if that's how you want to hear it
you're welcome to do that you're an
adult but no we agreed when we bought
your house you're going to stay with us
for a little while it's been two
years and then as I learned after many
years working with attorneys there is
power in the Paw I'm not going to seek
to fill that angsty silence or
discomfort I'm going to State my
boundaries very clearly and with love
and dignity and respect youall have to
leave my house
now and I can tell by your silence
there's no way this conversation is
happening is
there um I think my husband is to the
point that he is desperate for anything
okay I know he knows it's difficult but
I think he's willing to do what's going
to be best long term okay you are not
wimping out and you are not making him
quote unquote carry the burden by
himself by you not going to this meeting
it's appropriate for you to not be there
uhuh
okay I think you have significant input
on the front end of the conversation now
do youall get free babysitting and stuff
like
that his mother is our child care okay
y'all got have to deal with that yeah
cuz she might say screw you guys then
I'm going
home or he might say I need y'all to
move out we need our own place Mom I
would still like to hire you to be our
child care person
yeah have all have him map all that out
y'all two map all that out together but
remember she's an adult and she gets to
do whatever she wants she get it's her
life and if she wants to throw a temper
tantrum and walk away from
her grandkids and her son and his his
great wife that was suck but she gets to
do
that if she recognizes yeah we need to
leave this you're
right then and she wants to stay and it
works out great she wants to stay
childcare provider
awesome but here's what's happening very
quickly and it's not fair to Mom or to
new
dad y'all are growing to resent them
yeah when they call when they walk in
when the car pulls
up you're growing to really be disgusted
by
them and I don't think that's their
fault should they have left by now yes
they're
not and so you can't in one hand put out
your hand to have somebody shake it and
then be grossed out or disgusted or
angry when they shake it
back it's your job to not extend your
hand anymore
and so I'd much rather preserve the
relationship with my mom and my new dad
even if it's when it's
uncomfortable instead of being angry or
resentful every time they call or show
up to the place quite frankly I invited
him to
live it makes
sense I know it's not easy though
can I high five you from Nashville I
know this this just sucks for
you and I I'm tell I'll just reiterate
this again if you all go spend hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of dollars to
avoid this this season you're going to
lose a lot of respect for your husband
and you're going to feel pretty isolated
and on your
own well that was my argument I felt
like we were just running and not
solving any issue you are a wise wise
woman so I mean I but I mean from his
perspective he's like I just need some
time to think and he but I don't think
that's really gonna solve it there's
nothing to think about how long has it
been two years yeah two
years
Tada
Tada two years there's nothing else to
think about that's just a that's a
that's an avoidance strategy that's
punting on back down there's no reason
to do
it there's no reason to do
it just delaying the
inevitable this is his conversation to
have with his mother and his
dad and you and your husband come up
with the terms of this thing here's how
much you got 90 days you got six months
I don't care what the date is but it has
to be a firm date that y'all communicate
to
them possibly in writing I don't know if
they're renting the house from you but
y'all can decide that but there needs to
be it needs to be unambiguous everybody
needs to be clear as we say around here
where I work clear is
kind and expect some frustration some
sad some what of course they've they've
grown accustomed to living in your life
and y'all have become their
entertainment y'all have become their
insta family yall are their source
of like shelter probably food and it's
time for you and your husband to grow up
on your own and get your own place and
if your husband's struggling with OCD
and ADHD it's his job to go get the help
he needs I know because I've been there
that's his
job what a mess do me a favor call me
after this conversation because I'm
interested to know how it goes and we'll
put you back on the air or if he wants
to call and practice the call or
whatever I'm happy to talk to him too
but I'm interested to hear how this goes
and for everybody listening out
there it always sounds like a good idea
y'all just move in quote unquote for a
while whether you're adult with adult
kids or vice
versa you're adult kids and you're like
oh yall just Mom and Dad y'all just move
in for a while Mom just move in for a
while you can live in the basement for a
while always have a date on there always
you can revisit the date but always have
some clarity otherwise it gets into this
swampy mess and everybody comes out
smelling like swamp
gas and unless you're Kelly GH that's
gross she's kind of into it it's just a
thing